Daniel: And it's a great segue from
collective behavior in surprise
minimizing agents to collective behavior
in surprise minimizing agents, I guess.
Welcome, Conor.
Conor: Hey.
Sorry, I just turned on my audio, so I
just heard the last thing you said.
Yeah.
Hey, welcome.
Yes, thanks.
Daniel: Um, we're looking forward to your
presentation.
Multi agent active inference and
multiscale alignment, current
developments and challenges.
So feel free to share your screen or
proceed however you prefer.
Conor: Great, thanks.
And before I start, because I've had
issues with my voice saturating, like my
microphone saturating, how's my audio?
Is it clipping at all?
Or does this sound okay?
Daniel: This is good and I'm watching it.
.
Conor: Okay, perfect.
Thank you.
I will share my screen.
Share this one.
Daniel: The one thing I'll note oh, yes.
Conor: OK.
Daniel: It's just JF symbolic
implementation does not use statistical
distributions.
It uses the symbolic and the logical
inference.
And now we're going to move back into the
distributional space, and it will be
awesome to see similarities and
differences.
So thank you, Conor, to you for the
presentation.
Conor: And thank you, Daniel, for the
introduction and for inviting me, as well
as big thank you to the other organizers
of the Third Applied Active Influence
Symposium.
Yeah, I'm really happy to be here to
present.
So.
My name is Conor Heins.
I'm a PhD student at the Max Planck
Institute of Animal Behavior.
And I'm also a researcher at the Versus
AI research lab.
R D lab.
So I'm going to do something a little bit,
, I guess, unconventional for people in
my position.
Like, I'm a junior researcher coming to
the end of my PhD.
So usually when I give a talk, I would
present on my own research, like what I'
've been up to for the last ten years
working on.
But instead of that, I'm actually going
to talk about given the motivation of the
symposium, I'm going to talk about
something that's more of an overview or
perspective on the current state of the
field in multiscale active inference or
multi agent active inference and what, in
my opinion, we need to do to move forward
as a field.
I think that's very resonant with the
kind of motivations and the title, indeed,
, of this symposium.
So I'm going to give a general analysis
of what multiscale active inference is,
why it's important.
I'm going to provide a brief analysis of
its formal basis as it currently stands,
and then what we need to develop in this
kind of subdiscipline of active inference,
, multiscale active inference, to really
make it rigorous and really to actually
reap the benefits of what it promises.
So generally, active inference has been
used a lot to design agents that can
solve problems, plan, and just generally
emulate behavior that we deem intelligent,
, which includes things like risk
sensitive decision making, intrinsic
motivations to resolve uncertainty, and
finally, from a more scientific
standpoint, the ability to furnish a
process theory about how biological
brains actually might work.
But in a lot of the theoretical work on
active inference from the last ten years
or ten plus years, really, there's also
alongside all the kind of practical
building adaptive agents, there's a claim
that active inference is inherently or
intrinsically multiscale from the very
get go.
It is a multiscale framework.
It's not just about building single
agents.
So it's really whenever we write down a
single active inference agent, what we're
implicitly implying is also a nested
hierarchy of active inference agents both
below and above.
So colloquially, you'll often see this in
papers as the idea that there's Markov
blankets all the way down Markov blanket
is a statistical structure that's very
kind of intrinsic to the definition of
agents as they are defined under active
inference.
So I'm not going to get into defining
that.
I'm kind of assuming that there's a more
disciplinarian audience there, but I'm
sure other talks, for instance, can
provide better clarity.
So yeah, Markov blanket's active
inference all the way down, all the way
up.
And at any given scale, crucially, the
free energy minimizing dynamics, or the
active inference dynamics are kind of
claimed to be aligned with or parallel to
the free energy minimizing gradients at
the level below and above.
So the claim is that as agents are doing
their thing and doing active inference at
one level, it both entails and is
constrained by active inference processes
of the macro agent that they're
participating in.
So I'm a cell that's part of a tissue as
well as the micro agents that comprise
them.
I am a free energy minimizing cellular
agent comprised of organelles that are
also minimizing free energy.
So this kind of constrained neat nested
gradient descent on free energy is part
of the story of multiscale active
inference.
And it also crucially, assumes that these
dynamics are aligned, correlated
cooperative across these different scales.
.
So I should mention that there is a
formal argument made more recently, I
would say in the last five years, about
how this is possible.
And it relies on an apparatus from
statistical physics called the
Renormalization group.
This basically allows you to analytically
identify shared symmetries energy and
conservation laws at different scales in
a given system that's comprised of
subsystems and subsystems, so on
infinitum.
So there's a formal argument specifically
made in a free energy principle for a
particular physics monograph in 2019 that
applies the renormalization group
apparatus to multivariate stochastic
differential equations that are kind of
the equivalent of agents.
So you can apply that framework to
certain sorts of coupled stochastic
differential equations that exhibit
Markov blanketed sparse coupling
structure.
And you can kind of prove analytically
that there are going to be nested systems
of Markov blankets and that they're all
in some sense minimizing three energies
at their own scales.
So I'll get more into that argument later,
, but I just want to mention that as I
define multiscale active inference that
there is a formal argument that's related
to it.
So this slide I just put together to
demonstrate the idea of nested free
energy minimizing processes visually.
So at a given scale, we can think of an
agent as occupying some point in its free
energy landscape indicated by this red
orb, which represents, say, its
configuration, its beliefs, and its
actions.
And it performs active inference and in
doing so minimizes its free energy.
So it changes the position of that ball
on that landscape.
And that is all we mean when we say
active inference.
That corresponds to the agent doing
inference and doing action and kind of
getting to the fixed point of its local
free energy landscape.
The multi agent case is simply when we
add more of these processes.
So there's other agents usually assumed
to be similar agents, and the word
similarity, let's put an asterisk on that.
.
And they're all sitting at different
points in their own free energy
landscapes.
The position of their local red ball is
maybe in a different place.
So the claim of multiscale active
inference is that as we link these
multiple active inference agents together,
, so they can actually exchange
information like observations and actions
with each other, what we automatically
get is some kind of superagent that is
also minimizing variation of free energy
and is in some sense an emergent or
Supervenient active inference agent.
And I say the word, we automatically get
a superagent with an asterisk because
there may be some conditions on that
mapping from local to global that have to
be elucidated.
So we'll come back to that in a bit.
But in short, I think the definition of
multiscale active inference is very
eloquently put in this paper by Rafael
Kaufman, Pranav Gupta, and Jacob Taylor.
I think Rafael Kaufman is actually going
to be on the panel later.
And this line from their paper is a
really nice, I think, just summary of
what it is.
So I'll just read it out loud.
The upshot is that in theory, any active
inference agent at one Spaciotemporal
scale could be simultaneously composed of
nested active inference agents at the
scale below and constituent of a larger
active inference agent at the scale above
it.
In effect, active inference allows you to
pick a composite system or agent A that
you want to understand.
And it will be generally true that both
that agent A is an approximate global
minimizer of free energy at the scale at
which that agent reliably persists, and
that agent A is composed of subsystems A,
sub I that are approximate local
minimizers with free energy.
So that is the claim as I'm going to
continue evaluating in this talk, and I
think it's just a great reference point
to make, okay, that's what multiscale
active inference is.
Why is it important?
Why do we actually care about that?
That sounds philosophically nice and
beautiful visually, but why is that
important?
So there's a ton of actually really
important implications of this, both for
the engineering and the natural sciences.
.
First of all, the namesake of this
symposium, I assume inspired by this
recent paper by Karl Frison and all about
enacting ecosystems of parenthetically
shared intelligence.
So this is the third applied active
inference symposium.
So to really make this resonate with the
applied aspect, let's make this very
concrete.
If we can figure out this multiscale
endeavor, then we can actually engineer
distributed systems of multiaging
intelligence where local agents, in doing
their own little local active inference
processes, are also cooperatively
instantiating a global agent that's also
performing active inference.
This has huge computational potential, of
course, compared to kind of the state of
the art predominant methods for
artificial intelligence, which are deep
learning, which really is about
propagating global information through an
entire computation graph.
So although you could argue back
propagation is local in some sense, it's
really not local in the way that
multiscale active inference progresses to
be local.
So if we can figure out how to actually
engineer multiscale active inference, it
will have really tremendous implications
for the study of artificial intelligence
just from that pure engineering
standpoint.
It'll be cheaper.
In one word, it'll be computationally
energetically, memory wise.
Cheaper.
A lot cheaper.
Secondly, from a kind of more natural
sciences motivation, which is kind of
where I'm coming from, I'm doing a PhD in
biology, so I'm interested in questions
about actual real systems in nature.
Just the idea of being able to get super
specific and rigorous about phrases like
emergent intelligence, emergent
computation, collective intelligence,
superorganism that's often thrown around.
.
We're talking about social insects,
right?
These are terms that you hear thrown
around in many different scientific
disciplines that deal with multi agent
systems, network systems.
But none of these terms, to my knowledge,
have really rigorous or precise
conditions.
Multiscale active inference is a kind of
framework that's in the position to
provide those rigorous definitions and
conditions.
So from a scientific standpoint, it could
really lend a lot of potential and
usefulness for other scientific
disciplines.
And finally, another pragmatic motivation.
.
There's loads of fields that are obsessed
with designing and engineering systems
where local, selfish individual behavior
can lead when networked appropriately to
some desired collective outcome.
And these disciplines really want to
figure out how to engineer that properly.
.
So this goes from the design of financial
markets and trading systems all the way
down to how do you design a multiplayer
video game?
So that's kind of just motivating.
Why is multiscale active inference even
interesting?
So then the question, of course, becomes,
is the multiscale active inference claim
actually true?
Are all multi agent active inference
systems comprised of and themselves
comprise nested hierarchy of free energy
minimization agents?
A glance at a smattering of other
scientific disciplines that specifically
deal with multiple agents, multiple
interests, collective phenomena like
coordination, group behavior, collective
intelligence.
A glance at all those disciplines would
naively suggest that the answer is no.
So there's things like frustration in
thermodynamic systems game theory, the
very existence of zero sum games and mass
equilibria bandwagon effects when we're
talking about social networks and opinion
dynamics.
Sacrifices for the common good, which we
see in different contexts in biology,
like in the context of kin selection, but
also in the context of arguably cell
death in a tissue.
These are all basically plenty of systems
where local constraints and global
constraints or desires or free energy
gradients, whatever you want to call them,
, come into direct conflict.
So the obvious example that I listed at
the top of these bullets is the idea of
geometric frustration that we see in
Icing systems with very low temperature.
So these Icing models basically describe
lattices of Ferromagnets that are happy
when they're pointing in the same
direction as their neighboring
Ferromagnets and they can be in an up or
a down state.
So basically the magnet can be pointing
up or pointing down.
And these global systems are defined by a
global energy function and the whole
system is in some sense trying to
minimize that global energy function.
But sometimes you'll find cases in these
collective systems where this little spin
in the middle cannot be happy because
they're getting conflicting information
from two neighbors.
I want to be pointing up in blue like the
agent on the left, but I also want to be
pointing down like the agent on the right.
.
So this is a system that's collectively
finding some fixed point of its global
free energy, but it's actually leading to
a local conflict where this agent is not
at a point where it can do anything to
make itself happy or minimize its free
energy further.
So just from even the basic glance at
Ferromagnetic lattices, we already see
instances where local and global
gradients or local and global optima are
not aligned in the right way.
So given all this, the burden of proof
for multiscale active inference is still
on us.
So we need to show that collective active
inference systems generically do align
again across scales.
And maybe if we can put an X across the
word generically and it's not some
automatic condition, if they don't, then
at least we have to establish exactly the
conditions in which they do.
So anecdotally we do actually have some
conditions.
There seem to be some kind of basic
ingredients to get collective active
inference to work.
So one is that we basically need agents
to exchange actions and sensations across
some kind of Markov blanket.
This is not really a condition.
This is almost more part of what it means
to be an agent.
So having Markov blanket separation
between agents is just another way of
saying we have multiple agents in our
system rather than a single agent if you'
're violating the Markov blanket property.
.
So internal states of one agent are not
allowed to see the internal states or
external states of another agent.
Then you're kind of cheating because you'
're kind of saying it's actually one
agent.
And what you're doing is information
sharing within the brain of a single
agent.
The second condition, which is something
that's often hallucinated more
anecdotally and not really formally, is
this idea that agents need to have some
kind of shared narrative or shared hidden
states or censor space in their
generative model.
So I've worked a lot on collective active
inference systems, just simulating agents
and trying to get them to do interesting
things together.
And my intuitions and experience do agree
with this basic fact.
If the agents don't have any similarity
in what they're representing or trying to
achieve, then it's kind of like trying to
fit a square peg into a circular hole.
So this is really nicely elucidated in
one of the earliest cases in this paper,
a Duet for One by first and Fritz in 2015,
, where they show that for two agents to
really align, they kind of have to have a
shared generative model and then you can
get kind of this nice synchronized
behavior.
Again, though, these things like what
does similarity mean?
What does a shared narrative actually
mean?
Formally, mathematically, those things
have not been initiated yet.
So right now, a lot of the building of
these collective systems is based on our
intuitions and kind of engineering things
using some vague guidelines like, oh,
they should have a shared sensor space,
but there's no mathematical conditions or
guarantees about what degree of
similarity is needed between two agents
models to get the intended dynamics.
And finally, we have to have at least
some agreement between the generative
model of each agent and the generative
process, which is really the behavior of
the other agents generating their data.
So this is kind of related to the
previous point about having shared
generative models.
But just to be very specific, the physics
of the space that transfers your actions
to my observations that physics can't be
dramatically crazily different than how
our generative models represent those
physics.
So if we took two fish with the same
generative model of each other and they
normally would school together in a fish
tank, but we throw them in a volcano or
shoot them out into outer space they won'
't.
School together.
Because then the generative process is so
dramatically deviating from the way they
are representing that physics, the way
their generative model is constructed.
So these are, again just ingredients,
kind of guidelines or anecdotes.
But there's nothing really rigorous
behind these conditions.
They're more like a list of best
practices.
So now let's get on to actual rigorous
stuff.
So, the first real rigorous attempt to
show that multiscale active inference
generally works is in one section of this
free energy principle for a particular
physics monograph from 2019.
So it leverages this apparatus I
mentioned earlier, the Renormalization
group operator, to basically show how one
can successively coarse grain
multivariate stochastic differential
equations that admit sparse coupling
between their state variables.
So the main result in my mind that
connects these renormalization group
results to multiscale active inference is
the fact that the Lagrangian of the
system at one scale can be expressed as a
function of the Lagrangian at other
scales.
And that applies in a scale invariant
fashion that is the main kind of output
or the main benefit of using a
renormalization group apparatus.
So you can kind of think of Lagrangian
like the generative model.
It's a physics term, but it's related to
the generative model of the agents that
comprise the system and therefore also
their free energy.
So in terms of active inference, it means
that this reasoning of the
renormalization group can be used to
smoothly move between the models of
individual agents at one scale and the
model of a collective or larger agent at
a different scale or a smaller scale for
that matter.
And the nice thing about it is general
for all kinds of dynamics and thus
generative models, it doesn't depend
heavily on the form of the stochastic
differential equations that form your
system.
The issues with it is that there's not a
global link to Bayesian mechanics and
active inference.
It's still all done in the traditional
physics formalism.
So we don't actually have an explicit
link to local inference and global
inference.
Although if you know the connection
between the Lagrangian and the generative
model and the free energy, then you can
make that connection.
But it's not actually made explicitly for
us in this part of the monograph.
It also requires the assumption that the
generative model and the generative
process are identical at the local level
that's related to how the Lagrangian is
defined.
That's also restrictive assumption.
That's probably not realistic in my
opinion.
And then finally, there's something about
kind of spatiotemporal segregation of
scales.
So we need to make assumptions about how
fast random fluctuations are at one scale
relative to another scale in order to
justify kind of coarse grading or
forgetting about certain states as you
move between scales.
And that's also something that you could
argue.
Current research into collective dynamics
challenges that assumption about how fast
noise is at one scale relative to the
next.
So now I'm going to discuss quickly
another small contingent of active
inference research that is attempted to
address this mapping between local and
global inference processes.
So what I want to kind of just generally
say with this presentation and to our
community is that the kind of approach
taken in these two papers, first of all,
active inference model of collective
intelligence and spin glass systems as
collective active inference.
This is one of the types of research I
think we really need to move active
inference, multiscale active inference
forward.
So I'm not trying to be too biased
because I am the first author on the
second of those papers, but I'll also be
the first one to point out the limitation.
.
But benefits wise, I think these
approaches are really important because
they formally relate a local generative
model at one scale to a global generative
model at a different scale.
So really tie, how do the parameters of
one model relate to a course grade
model?
And these are really good steps in the
direction of a formal theory of
collective intelligence that goes from
local intelligences to global
intelligence.
However, there's still issues with these.
.
One of them is that they only deal with
issue with inference at the global level,
not active inference.
So both these papers concern with a bunch
of local active inference agents that
cooperate to form a global inference
agent, like a passive baying agent,
rather than an active inference agent.
And it's also unclear whether the systems
studying these papers are actually very
generic.
Like the results are generic to studying
collective intelligence in general, or
they're nice formal arguments, but they'
're only applicable to these specific
systems.
So we still don't have something that's
even more kind of zoomed out and abstract
than these, which tend to be a little bit
case specific.
And finally, the actual scale
transcendence that we're doing in these
papers is still relegated to really one
step.
We're not doing the full multiscale
infinite scale regression that something
like Renormalization group promises.
So that's kind of the current overview of
what I think are the most promising
directions in multiscale active inference.
.
And I'm aware on time, sorry, five
minutes.
So I'm going to quickly try to go through
what I think are really promising
directions to push in terms of multiscale
active inference and kind of intuition
pumps that I think will help us study
these systems in a way that's different
and also actually better informed by
other research disciplines.
So the general idea that I'd like to put
forward is that misaligned gradients can
actually be a good thing.
So it's actually sometimes good when
local free energy gradients are
misaligned with global gradients.
So sometimes the global system will
actually do better if the local systems
are performing worse.
So this is something you could call
multiscale conflict, where the free
energy minimizing processes at one scale
are actually doing bad, quote unquote,
but it's because they're being driven by
some higher scale process that is doing
well.
So rather than trying to always avoid
constructing processes like this, I think
this kind of frustration, to use the
analogy from statistical physics, can
actually be an inspiration for what we
should investigate further because it
actually might be key to facilitating
optimality at different scales.
The reason I put this forward is because
there's loads of research, just recent
research in the last several years that
are suggesting that actually making local
agents more frustrated or more unhappy
might coincidentally or not
coincidentally lead to better collective
or global outcomes.
So this is expressed in various forms in
various bodies of work.
One of the biggest patterns I've noticed
is the study of collective behavioral
systems over the last several decades is
the idea that local noise and local
Dysregulation can often facilitate global
coherence or global coordination.
And where multiscale active inference has
something to say, in my opinion, is in
framing this benefit of local frustration
in terms of a misalignment of free energy
gradients.
So it may be that actually temporary
misalignment local free energy gradients
from global ones may facilitate the
descent to fix points in the global free
energy landscape that satisfy everyone at
all scales.
So I'm basically expressing an idea that'
's been known in various communities like
Stochastic optimization and Stochastic
resonance theory for decades.
But I think we as active inference
practitioners have a new and potentially
useful perspective to shed on that, using
the language of active inference and free
energy minimization and Bayesian
inference in general.
So instead of thinking of accelerating
optimization by just adding noise to the
system, we can think of exactly how to
design local generative models such that
there's an optimal misalignment of local
and global gradients or local and global
generative models in a way that
facilitates everyone in the long run
actually facilitating or minimizing their
free energy.
So yeah, that's just kind of like
something I'm putting out there.
I'm investigating it now in my own work,
but I have no real results on that.
But I just wanted to put that out there
in this venue because I think it maybe
will inspire other people to think in a
similar way.
So just to conclude, now, multiscale
active inference, I would say, is still
largely based on theoretical or
philosophical descriptions and
illustrious simulations, but we're still
lacking a formal theory.
There's some theory in terms of the
renormalization group arguments of the
monograph, but they're still, in my
opinion, a bit underdeveloped, a little
under demonstrated and relying on some
restrictive assumptions like the fast and
slow fluctuations, the identity between
generative model, generative process.
There's a few more recent papers, those
two by Kaufman at all and then by myself
on spingglass systems that have attempted
particular proofs of multi scale Bayesian
inference systems in particular
situations, but their generality is still
not known and not proven.
So what I'm kind of trying to conclude
with is by saying we need to incorporate
findings from other disciplines related
to the role of noise, conflict and
frustration in facilitating, not
subverting collective intelligence or
collective coordination.
And I think we can really benefit by
looking at these other disciplines to
help us build a really powerful formal
theory of multiscale active inference.
And finally, I think we need to set the
goalpost for what counts as a formal
proof of multiscale active inference.
And once we get there, once we're saying,
okay, this counts as proof, this is
satisfying, how can we use that to
actually do the hardest part, in my
opinion, which is engineering actual
multiscale active inference systems that
are intelligent and minimizing free
energy at multiple scales.
Yeah, so with that, I'm going to conclude
looks like I'm just on time.
So, yeah, thank you again for the
invitation to present, and I'd like to
thank a bunch of people who are listed
here and beyond who have influenced my
thinking and kind of my opinions.
If there's time, I'm happy to take any
questions.
Daniel: Awesome.
Great talk.
I'll just give a few seconds if anybody
wants to type in a question.
Also, it's really cool.
Like, aswin in the previous session was
highlighting Pymdp and just the way in
which we enact the collective
intelligence.
Different people seeing a paper where an
analytical formalization is introduced,
and then there's still so much work to
get it to the package, and then so much
more work to take it to the last mile.
And I think your presentation really
checked a lot of those boxes.
I'll just read a question and then that
will just be an appetizer for our
continued discussion.
So Marco Lynn asked, do you expect the
inferentially connected dynamics to
exhibit behavior akin to theories of
multi body systems?
And to what extent can we transfer
insights from that multi body of work?
And then second question, just for our
thinking and learning from Marco, have
you explored integrating work on self
organized criticality with multi scale
active inference or other frameworks?
Who can provide more flexible frameworks
or assumptions for a generic notion of
multiscale dynamics?
Great questions.
I hope that we can continue, have you
back anytime, or just continue to
collaborate in the ecosystem.
So thank you for the epic talk, Conor,
and good luck finishing your PhD.
Conor: Thanks a lot, Daniel.
Yeah, I'll talk to you soon.
Daniel: Talk to you soon.